Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my video for the Batman Beyond movie that
we just found out that they had been in the
middle of making when everything has been
canceled or delayed because of what James Gunn
did when he took over DC's Studios and them sort
of reimagining everything redoing the continuity
so to speak like soft reboot on everything I'll
explain what was supposed to happen during that
and what's changing going forward now with all
the big Justice League characters particularly
with Batman this is more of a Batman video
specifically if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos I'll
be doing a bunch of videos for everything because
it's still a developing situation like James Gunn
made an announcement I talked about what he said
specifically like I included his actual message
in my Wonder Woman 3 video yesterday because
that movie pretty much flat out canceled but
after the opening Salvo was fire like after we
started hearing about them canceling projects
actors moving on then recasting some of the big
Justice League actors basically doing a version
of what James Gunn did with the Suicide Squad
movie in the previous Suicide Squad film where
it's kind of Canon but it was a soft reboot
with the new characters his way of winking
from behind the camera addressing the change in
the continuity like some of the old actors some
of the old movies go away so to speak and some
of them continue on not everybody's going to
be recast but where we get to Batman Beyond and
Michael Keaton is The Flash movie it all starts
with The Flash movie they're still releasing
all the movies that they have planned for next
year none of that's changed there are a couple
of things that happen during those movies that
might wind up changing like Henry Cavill filmed
a post-credits scene specifically as Superman for
The Flash movie that might not wind up making it
into the movie is a bit of a question right now
because of Henry cavill's future as Superman at DC
Studios the DC movies in Ben Affleck also filmed
a cameo scene as Batman for the end of Aquaman 2
which is supposed to come out at the end of next
year there's also a question about whether or
not that will actually make it into the Final
Cut of the film too but as for right now Michael
Keaton is still one of the main characters during
The Flash movie that's not going to change it's
still going to be a big Multiverse movie for DC
during that movie Ezra Miller's flash is given
a brand new suit by Ben Affleck's Batman I think
that's going to pick up before the events of the
film like there was a tie-in comic book that's
supposed to explain how Batman gives him the new
suit but during that movie they're doing a version
of Flashpoint where he tries to find a way to save
his mother but winds up traveling to the Earth
that Michael Keaton's Batman is from we'll call
that Earth 89 now they might have some different
designation for it that they call out during The
Flash movie but most of the events take place on
that alternate Earth where the Michael Keaton
Batman movies took place the way that they're
explaining his character is that he's only been
through the events of Batman and Batman Returns
they're treating Val Kilmer Batman Forever and
George Clooney Batman and Robin as completely
separate universes like all that stuff happened
but they happen on other Earths not on Michael
Keaton's earth when he travels to that Earth this
other version of him this other Barry Allen is
meant to be the villain of the film you can see
he wears a Flash costume that's cobbled together
from the bones of an old Batman Michael Keaton
in suit so it's kind of like Flash versus dark
Flash and this other Barry Allen just seems
like he has problems with the whole idea of
their mother's death when he finds out that they
can actually change the timeline and potentially
bring her back to life that's basically what
the flashpoint story is All About is Barry Allen
learning to accept his mother's death like some
things have to happen like you can't change the
timeline on a whim because it leads to disastrous
consequences and that's kind of what plays out
through the Flash movie it's not going to be
like comic book Flashpoint they did an animated
Justice League Flashpoint movie as well it won't
be exactly like that but it'll have the same Vibes
at the end of that movie after they fix most
things probably not everything but some things
Ezra Miller's flash is supposed to return to the
main Justice League Universe with the idea that
there would be more interdimensional travel in the
future teasing the idea that the characters across
the Multiverse will continue to team up look we
have an idea for how to travel the Multiverse in
a more reliable way now so that anybody they want
could potentially come back in the future arguably
for Michael Keaton I think that they had initially
thought to set him up as the new crossover Batman
and because Matt Reeves didn't want to have Robert
Pattinson's Batman crossover and this is all long
before James Gunn signed on to take over as
the Kevin feige of DC Studios during his big
announcement post James gonna address this like
I understand I'm stepping into a very fractious
environment things are all over the place one
of the things that was addressing was the whole
Batman situation like if Ben Affleck is leaving
and Robert Pattinson isn't going to cross over
we have to have a Batman if we're going to do
future Justice League films who's going to be
that Batman for a little while the plan was to
have Michael Keaton be the crossover Batman and
he would play the sort of old Mentor role and
they would just tease that concept at the end
of The Flash movie but separately after the end of
the movie Michael Keaton's Batman would have gone
on to star in the Batgirl movie I've already
done a video about that because that was one
of the other canceled movies it was much more
public because it happened a little while ago
it got a lot more play in the news because it was
more of an isolated incident a while ago and all
this stuff just got announced all at the same
time like a bunch of different movies a bunch
of different actors also too because the Batgirl
movie was essentially finished like it was picture
are locked ready to go they could have dropped it
or leaked it quote unquote on purpose kind of the
next day obviously they didn't because the people
that directed it tried to log into the servers to
grab a copy of it and within moments of the
announcement being made they've been locked
out of the servers the thing about the Batgirl
movie is that the way they treated the continuity
the Easter eggs or the characters from across the
Multiverse were a little nebulous like it was kind
of vague as to which Earth it took place on there
were a lot of Snyder vs Easter eggs during it so
it was like is it happening on the Snyder versus
Earth is it happening on the main Justice League
Earth so far obviously that's changing going
forward or is it said on the earth that Michael
Keaton's Batman is from they never really answered
that during the events of the film but during that
movie Michael Keaton's Batman wasn't meant to be
a main character the way that they talked about
it they called it more of a glorified Cameo where
he shows up gives her some advice and acknowledges
their previous relationship his relationship
with Jim Gordon her father it was going to be the
Snyder versus version of Jim Gordon coming back
the JK Simmons Jim Gordon that's why I say they
were kind of Vegas to which Earth it took place
on with all the Easter eggs but he'd show up give
her some advice then go off on his own she go off
on her own day to day and just become a superhero
in her own right then after that is when we get
to the live action Batman Beyond movie after that
he would go on to the Batman Beyond film and
it would have been in the same tone the same
vibe from the Batman Beyond animated series with
a version of live-action Terry McGinnis becoming
the next Batman taking the mantle getting the new
Batman Beyond suit it would have been a copy-paced
version of the Animated Series like it would have
been the exact same plot Michael Keaton is in his
60s right now he's not that old Kevin Conroy's
Batman was meant to be a future version of the
same one from Batman the Animated Series in his
80s may he rest in peace now Kevin Conroy was
amazing before he passed away though he did get to
play a live-action version of Batman during crisis
on infinite Earths battle not with monsters lest
you become a monster in Batman Beyond I played
um an older Bruce Wayne he still had hope for the
world I can barely walk let alone wear that again
this Bruce Wayne he's become so broken and so
embittered by life that he sees no hope for the
world and the Bruce I knew more a different kind
of suit lifetime of injuries the point of this
exoskeleton is to support his body because he's
been so beaten and broken that he would not be
able to stand up without it and then they turn it
on and I go no I never thought I'd get a chance
to do it on camera because I was getting older and
older and older I was sort of Aging out of Batman
you know but luckily I aged into Old Bruce Wayne
that version was meant to be in amalgam of Kingdom
Come Batman with the harness and Batman Beyond
the Bruce Wayne from that series because the Earth
that that was taking place on was Earth 99 and
the 99 was a reference to the Batman Beyond series
which debuted in 1999 but I believe they would
have set up the idea that he passes the mantle
to a version of live-action Terry McGinnis and he
plays a version of the character that you saw in
the animated series and they would just continue
those movies on in its own line of continuity in
the future so I think one of the reasons why James
Gunn put the kibosh on that project before they
start filming is because they don't want to have
a billion different versions of live-action Batman
it was already kind of confusing to begin with
like I am excited to see Michael Keaton come back
as a version of Multiverse Batman but really if
we're talking about a main version of Batman you
only want one and that's technically supposed
to be Matt Reeves Robert Pattinson Batman he
even has his own line of continuity even though
they have all these big changes happening at DC
they're not changing anything about what Matt
Reeves is doing with his version of Batman is
still in its own self-contained Universe for now
of all the craziness they said that they weren't
touching a couple things they weren't going to
mess with anything that Matt Reeves was doing
with his version of Batman and they're not messing
with anything that Todd Phillips is doing with his
version of Joker so like Joker 2 is going to do
its own thing the Batman 2 gonna do its own thing
they have all the HBO spin-offs like the Arkham
series The Penguin series that they're doing from
Robert Pattinson's Batman those will continue on
in development like they had originally planned
the Penguin series will be the first one to
Premiere that won't happen until 2024 though
of all the craziness that's happening right now
just big reminder that they're still releasing
all the movies next year they still have Shazam
Fury the Gods coming out normally no big changes
there The Flash movie during the summer then the
Blue Beetle movie then Aquaman 2 at the end of the
year I know there's still tons of questions about
what's happening with Henry Cavill Superman which
actors will they actually wind up recap casting
amongst the Justice League I'll do a separate
video about that because even Jason Momoa has
already talked about Aquaman 2 being his last
movie as Aquaman make sure you enable alerts for
my channel so you don't miss that there's just so
much stuff that happened in the last couple of
weeks like I said it's a developing situation
so I will continue to do new videos as we get more
information about what James Gunn's actual plan is
for the next 10 years of DC as of me posting this
video he's making an official presentation to the
Warner Brothers board the CEO about what that plan
is going to be and then they'll probably make more
public announcements on his Twitter account about
the future of the universe speaking of James Gunn
I just did a big Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
video click here to watch that and click here for
my brand new Star Wars Jedi Survivor trailer
video with Mandalorian and Ahsoka Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!